CHET HAASE: Hi, I'm Chet
Haase from the
Android team at Google.
I work on graphics and
animation stuff here.
And today I wanted to talk about
some animation stuff.
Surprise, surprise.
Specifically I wanted to talk
about View Animations, which
is the set of the animation APIs
that are available prior
to the 3.0 release.
So there's some more modern APIs
that we'll talk about in
future episodes, but for now
we'll talk about the APIs that
you might want to use if you're
running on devices that
are running platforms prior
to the 3.0 release.
So View Animations were created
specifically for
animating individual properties
of views.
It's not a general purpose
animation engine, but a way to
achieve specific visual effects
for your user interface.
So let's take a look at a demo,
which I called View
Animations.
We have a few buttons on the
screen that are named after
the animations that are
going to be run when
you click on them.
So we have an alpha animation,
a translate animation that
moves the button around, rotate
animation, a scale
animation, and then a set
animation is basically a way
to choreograph several
animations on the same object.
So we run all of those types
of animations on that one
button to give a really horrible
effect, which I
expect to not see in any
of your applications.
Now all of these animations that
we're running here were
created and run in code, but
you can also load them from
animation resources,
which we'll see in
the code in a minute.
So we can get exactly the same
types of effect loading from
XML resources instead.
So now let's take a
look at the code.
So we have this class called
View Animations.
It's an activity.
We have a check box that
controls whether we load from
resources or create these
on the fly in code.
We have the buttons that
are created here.
We have alpha, translate,
rotate, scale, set, and then
we listen for clicks on those
buttons and run the animations
appropriately.
This is the interesting part
about how the animations are
actually created, so this is how
you create some of these
animations in code.
So here's an alpha animation.
We say we want an alpha
animation, it's going to go
from 1 to 0.
That's basically saying from
fully opaque to fully
transparent.
And we're going to
set the duration.
Note that view animations don't
have a default duration,
so you need to set a duration to
have any animation at all,
otherwise they'll just happen
atomically and immediately,
which is probably not the kind
of animation effect you're
looking for.
We have a translate animation
that's going to be moving in
both x and y, and you have the
ability to move in absolute
coordinates or relative to self
or relative to parents.
You can basically say, I want
to move for half of my
parent's width, for example.
Again, we set the duration
and that animation
is on rotate animation.
Again we have the concept of
being relative to self,
relative to parent, and we have
a pivot point that we're
rotating around.
Here we're pivoting around the
center point of the button
itself, so it's just going to
rotate around its center.
Set the duration
and we're done.
Scale animation, we're going to
scale in both x and y, from
1 to 2, which is saying
from my normal 100%
size to 200% size.
And the set animation is a way
of combining all of these
animations to run all on the
same button to give that
really horrible effect
that we saw.
We set up each of these
animations, which is just a
method that I created to say
either use the animations that
are created above or create
them from resources, which
we'll see in a minute.
And then we listen
in on the button.
When the button has clicked,
then we run the animation
appropriately.
So that's the code
side of this.
The resource side we can take
a look at, and it should be
fairly straightforward.
If you understand how to create
these in code, you'll
understand what the attribute
names are in the XML resource.
So here's the alpha animation.
We say from an alpha of 1 to an
alpha of 0 duration we're
going to make this a little bit
faster in XML resources.
Rotate, we've got two degrees
360, so it's basically going
to spin an entire cycle and
it's going to pivot around
half of its own width.
So it's got a center point right
it in its center for the
rotation scale animation here.
From x and y of 1, so that's
from its normal 100% size to
an x and y scale of
2, so going to
200% duration of 1,000.
And here's the set.
So this is how we choreograph
animations and do several
things either in parallel
or in sequence.
We're actually doing all of
these all together, so they're
going to happen all at the same
time to give to the most
egregious effect possible.
But you can stagger these
in time as well by
using a start offset.
Here we have an alpha animation
that's going to kick
off at the same time as the
rotate animation, same time as
the scale animation, and
at the same time as
the translate animation.
So to load these we can go back
and look at the code and
instead of just running the
animation that we created in
code above we do a animation
utils load animation, and load
it from the resource ID
that we specified.
So the takeaway from this today
is, it's fairly easy to
create these things and to run
these animations and get some
simple effects, basically moving
things around on the
screen and fading them in and
out, which can be a very
powerful tool to help your users
understand what's going
on in your UI.
Fade the things in that are
coming into view, fade them
out if they're going away, move
things into position, and
basically give a more immersive
and intuitive
experience to your users.
In future episodes we'll see
alternate ways of doing this
kind of stuff as well as
other, more powerful,
animations.
Thanks for tuning in.